你有沒有發現
生活中的小意外
真的是說來就來
像是被
蚊子叮咬
燙傷
或者媽媽在切菜的時候
一不小心切到手了
怎麼處理復原的最快呢
中醫治病分成
外因 內因 不內外因
剛剛我說的這些外傷呢
它就是屬於不內外因
我來教你
幾個實用的急救妙招
簡單又有效
胡乃文開講囉
我是你的老朋友 胡醫師
這一集要和你分享
1.被蚊子叮狂抓 2招快速止癢
2.切到手該如何止血？急救4步驟
3.牙膏或麵粉NG 燙傷塗它不留疤
4.煎魚、炸物被油噴？3種油抗發炎
5.被狗咬怎麼辦？敷1物好的快
被蚊子叮狂抓 2招快速止癢
你相信嗎
一個小蚊子包
居然差點
變成蜂窩性組織炎
在一個網路平台
有一位媽媽分享
這個網路平台是什麼呢
小編跟我說
是年輕人愛用的
一種社群平台啦
這位媽媽
說她去咖啡廳
被咬了六個包
其中有一個包
越來越癢
還滲出來組織液
痛到走不動
最後去看皮膚科醫生才知道
齁 已經感染了
醫生說
再嚴重下去
就是
蜂窩性組織炎啦
哇 太嚴重了吧
我阿嬤都說抹一點口水
很快就不癢了
這有用嗎
小編啦
我跟你說一個故事
有一個人打麻將
打了一整個晚上
隨時的覺得有點癢
以為是蚊子咬
就塗一下
用口水這樣塗一下
結果呢
一整晚打完麻將之後
起身
恩 怎麼搞的
後頭死了一條蛇
什麼 為什麼
原來蛇舔了他背上的口水啦
被毒死囉
雖然只是故事
但口水確實有一點毒性
我在讀大學的時候
讀到過
人的口水跟狗的口水
都是有毒的
能短暫的止癢
所以有人
覺得擦了會比較不癢
不過我不建議
你用口水來止癢哦
為什麼
口水也有許多的
不知道的東西
像細菌之類的
尤其是小朋友
一癢就抓
手不乾淨再抹口水
那個手上面
又是什麼東西啊
容易感染細菌
或者是其他的一些個病源
我來跟你說
不用藥的天然止癢法
兩招把它學起來
第一招 冰敷五分鐘
讓血管收縮
減輕癢感和腫脹
如果手邊沒有冰塊
用其他東西能替代嗎
你拿冰的飲料嘛
冰箱裡面的飲料拿起來
然後用乾淨的布包著
就放在那個叮的地方
然後呢
十秒鐘壓它一下
十秒鐘壓一下
這樣持續大概五分鐘
就可以
緩解那個癢的感覺囉
第二招 用泡過的茶包
茶包中含有鞣酸啊
就叫做單寧酸是不是
有收斂的作用
能夠收縮血管
減少滲出液和癢的感覺
夏天小黑蚊很多
有沒有天然驅蚊的方法
有
用丁香
丁香是一味中藥
它的香氣
也能夠驅蚊的喔
你可以到中藥店裡頭去買
所謂丁香
又不貴的東西
把它分裝成一小袋一小袋
放在陽台窗邊
各個角落
無毒又安全滿不錯的喔
切到手該如何止血 急救4步驟
不只是被蚊子咬
另外一種經常發生
是在廚房裡頭
切東西切到手
當然啦
媽媽們能夠自己做菜
那是最好喔
那你一定要懂
人在廚房裡
哪有不挨刀的
當你正在切菜
削水果的時候
一不小心
一不留神就
哇切到手了
你該怎麼樣處理呢
媽媽們很多都是拿貼布來貼
是不是
就是一個
繃帶就是了
沒錯
切到手血流不止怎麼辦
記住這四個步驟
第一步 先止血
止血的方法很簡單
乾淨的紗布或者餐巾紙
壓住那個傷口讓血止住
第二步 消毒傷口
注意等到血已經止住之後
開始用來清潔傷口
用酒精 碘酒 優碘等等來消毒
第三步 塗藥
確認沒有再出血
擦一層
抗菌的藥膏
防止感染
最後第四步 包紮
用剛才講的
貼布
或者紗布
包起來就是了
中醫裡面有一個止血高手
你知道叫什麼嗎
叫田七
它不只是可以止血
最棒的地方
它就是能夠
防止結痂
傷口不留疤
跟你說一個有趣的故事
四十多年前
我帶我的小孩去打球
結果呢 我摔跤了
那只好到
外科醫生去給看一下吧
那個外科醫生
抽屜一打開
我看到竟然的他那裡
放了一瓶藥
也就是說
連西醫他都用雲南白藥
雲南白藥的
主要成份就是田七
他就能夠幫助止血
讓傷口癒合得更快
連外科醫師也用中藥
那表示雲南白藥的效果
真的很好囉
就是這個意思啊
牙膏或麵粉NG 燙傷塗它不留疤
醫師啊
我上次倒熱水來喝
然後要走回房間的路上
熱水就啪
滴到我腳趾
痛得我大腳
馬上去沖冷水
一邊沖 一邊想到你說的
撒鹽
撒了鹽以後 哇
真的沒有起水泡耶
嘿
這個喔
你還反應得滿快喔
不然腳趾頭
可能就變成
焦糖脆皮了是吧
對啊 千萬不要喔
撒鹽是一個好方法
如果想不留疤的話
想要皮膚恢復得
水噹噹的話
我還有一個很棒的方法
就是滑石粉加橄欖油
把這兩樣東西混在一起
塗在燙傷的地方
滑石粉加橄欖油效果很好
記得我當時
大概在四十年前左右吧
我剛當中醫師的時候
我的一個同學
他不小心燙傷了
傷口過了一兩週
還沒有好
我建議他用滑石粉
配橄欖油攪成像膏狀的
然後塗到那個地方
很快就好了
哇都已經過了一兩週
還能不留疤
真的很讚
你們一定會問
那滑石粉到哪去買呢
你到中藥房去買就行了
便宜又好用
買不到的話呢
用大黃粉也可以
它有涼血消炎的功效
是不錯的替代選項喔
還有滑石粉
除了中藥房以外呢
在書店也可能買得到
書店裡頭它叫做算盤粉
因為以前人滑算盤的時候呢
用點滑石粉
那個算盤會比較滑
有些人會用牙膏或麵粉
敷在傷口上是可以的嗎
牙膏或麵粉
它沒有殺菌的作用
也沒有消炎的作用
所以我不建議啦
煎魚炸物被油噴 3種油減少發炎
除了燙傷
婆婆媽媽們
你在廚房煎魚炸食物的時候
是不是也會被油噴到
喔 油爆的時候啊
真的是很痛呢
這個時候
你身邊如果有三種油
趕快塗上去 很快就沒事
三種油
一 亞麻仁油
二 橄欖油
三 芝麻油
只要是冷榨的油都可以
注意啊
經過萃取的油
可能不行喔
為什麼冷榨的油有效呢
亞麻仁油
橄欖油
芝麻油
它們是冷壓
沒有精煉的版本
燙傷的時候啊
這些油
含有豐富的天然抗氧化物
和必需的脂肪酸
亞麻仁油裡頭啊
有Omega-3脂肪酸
橄欖油它的酚類化合物
芝麻油裡頭的芝麻酚
都具有抗發炎
抗氧化的效果
塗抹以後
可以幫助
減輕燙傷處的
紅腫發炎
並且呢
滋潤皮膚 加速修復
能夠避免傷口
乾裂脫皮
突然被狗咬怎麼辦 敷1物好得快
我朋友上禮拜被狗咬
當場流血
我聽完超害怕的
別緊張
狗咬這種事啊
不是說你想
它發生就發生了
不過說真的
嘿 還真有被咬到的時候
西醫第一件事情
就叫你到醫院去處理
給你打個破傷風針啊
或者是打個狂犬病的疫苗啊
等等
那當然之前
他就會幫你先沖洗傷口
消毒 然後呢
來繼續做這個醫療的處理
但是如果這樣做了
傷口還沒好呢
我就碰到過這樣的案例
大概是近一年的事情
有一個病人啊
他傷口好久沒有癒合呀
看遍了中醫西醫都沒辦法
最後找到我了
我給他調理了
大概一個多月
傷口終於癒合了
這麼神哦
你用了什麼仙丹妙藥啊
我告訴你
地榆根
這就是古人的智慧
例如在那個肘後備急方
葛洪呢他就說
他說把地榆根磨成粉
像喝中藥那樣
一天吃一到兩次
再把這個粉末呢
就敷在傷口上
就能夠讓傷口變好
好 我就讓他這樣子做了
那如果你買到的
是新鮮的地榆根呢
那就搗碎來用
敷在傷口上
就可以了
口服加外敷 雙管齊下
幫助傷口
收斂 止血 生肌
地榆根是涼血止血的藥
能夠消腫 解毒 收斂傷口
不只是能夠處理外傷
對於痔瘡出血
吐血 便血等出血的問題
也有幫助
喜歡這支影片的朋友
歡迎點擊影片下方的超級感謝
給我們支持喔